ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครีมสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วัน
พุธค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 13 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กรกฎาคมปีพตอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2  0  2  2 ค่ะตัด
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วัน
อังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
12 เดือนเดือน
คำคมปีพตตปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีค.ศต้ดมีข้อ
2022 ค่ะเกาะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันพฤหัสบดีวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
ที่ 14 เดือน
เดือน
กรกฎาคมปีพตตปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีค.ศต้ดมีข้อ
2022 ค่ะค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอน
นี้เวลา 11:00 น 11 โมงกี่นาที
11 นาทีน
11  11
ช้อปปิ้งหรอคะเอ้า Lazada  Shopping สุด
ดู
หนัง 9 อันนี้ก็วันพุธแล้วนะคะวันนี้
เนี่ยครูหญิงมีเกมมาเล่นกับครูฟ้าค่ะเกม
อะไรไม่เล่นเล่นสิ
โนเกมน้ำ
เกมอะไรอ่ะกูหญิงเกมเกี่ยวกับคำเปลว
เริญ
โปรไฟล์เนี่ยเป็นคนที่พูดเร็วจะไปหาอะไร
ครูฟ้าลองพูดเร็วๆให้นักเรียนฟังได้ไหม
พูดเร็วๆนะสวยคณะที่เรียนแถวนี้ช่วงนี้
ไม่ของเรานะคะรีบแผนกผู้หญิงเกมจะมาเล่น
ด้วยกันอะไรลูกเกมอะไรคะแล้วต้องรอฟังนะ
ว่าเห็นงั้นนั่งเรียนเราฟังแล้วแล้วเข้า
ใจกับภาษาไทยของครูบาและผู้หญิงนะมันง่าย
มากมันไม่ยากเลยนะแต่ว่าไม่รู้ใครชนะนะ
ครับวันนี้มันเกมที่น่าเล่นมากแล้วถึงว่า
เราสนใจมาให้เงินมาลองดูถ้า
นักเรียนปิดจะหนีไปแล้ว
เนี่ยพูดเร็วเร็วๆภูฟ้าคุณพูดเร็ววันนี้
เนี่ยเกมก็เกี่ยวกับความเร็ววครูฟ้าต้อง
ชนะแน่ๆเลยอ่ะ
เฮ้ยผู้หญิงคิดว่ากูฟ้าจะชนะล่ะวันนี้ใช่
ไหมคะเกมเนี่ยผู้หญิงเนี่ยจะมี
คำถาม
งู
ถามแล้วก็ครูฟ้ากับครูหญิงก็จะมีเวลายี่
สิบยี่สิบนาทีมันน้อยไปไหม 30 แล้วกันฉัน
ซื้อก็ได้
30 วินาทีที่จะตอบใช่ไหมตอบคำถามเนี่ยมี
เวลา 30 วินาทีก็ในเวลา 30 วินาทีเนี่ย
ครูหญิงกับครูป๊าก็ต้องแข่งกันตอบเร็วๆ
ใครตอบได้มากที่สุดพี่
ก๊อตจะนัดสนะแต่คำถามเนี่ยมันน่าจะมีไม่
ได้มี 1 ข้อในคำถามก็จะมีก็ที่ 1 ข้อที่ 2
ข้อที่ 3 ข้อที่สี่แล้วก็เอาคำตอบคำตอบทำ
ตอบช้างหมด 4 ข้อเอามารวมกันใครได้มากที่
สุดก็แปลว่าเราตอบเร็ว
สมัยถ้าครูฟ้าตอบเร็วแล้วผู้หญิง
คิดนานกับ AD ครูบาก็ได้ตอบ
แล้วถ้า
หรอแล้วมีชนะมีแพ้ไหมมีถ้ารวมกันแนนแล้ว
ทั้งหมดใครแพ้
ก็ต้องทำอะไรค่ะมะนาวอุ้ยครูหญิงแท้ผู้
หญิงก็ต้องกินอยาก
กินมะนาวการ์ดรูฝาแพ้ครูบาต้องบีบมะนาว
ใส่ตาค่ะเอ้าอุ้ยน้องผู้หญิง
ครูฟ้าก็ต้องกินมะนาวใครแท้งกินใครแพ้ก็
แปลว่าคนนั้นเนี่ยไม่เร็วค่าครูฟ้ามาชนะ
ครูฟ้าก็เป็นคนที่เร็วที่สุดถ้าครูหญิง
แท้ผู้หญิงก็ไม่เร็วใช่มั้ยก็ต้องกิน
มะนาวอ่ะค่ะอยากรู้อยากเล่นแล้วผู้หญิง
อยากเล่นอะเล่นใช่ไหมทำถามข้อที่ 1 นะคำ
ถามข้อที่ 1 เนี่ยนะคะเกี่ยวกับรูปนี้รูป
อะไรคะครูฟ้ารูปกีฬานักกีฬากีฬามีกีฬา
หลายๆชนิดนะคะคำถามข้อที่ 1 ก็คือครูฟ้า
แล้วก็ครูหญิงเนี่ยต้องตอบว่ากีฬาอะไรและ
ร้านที่เวลาที่เราเล่นเนี่ยมันจะต้องเร็ว
ๆใช้ความเร็ว
กีฬาอะไรที่ใช้ความเร็วนิสัยกว่างเร็วใช่
ค่ะอะอย่างสมุดอันนี้มันจะมีอะไรเนี่ย
อันดับเหรอไม่ใช่ใช่มั้ยชกมวยอย่างเงี้ย
อะไม่ได้ใช้ความเร็วกีฬาอะไรที่ใช้ความ
เร็วนะคะซึ่ง
แล้ว
R คุณก็ต้องมีตรวจจับเวลา
30 วินาทีนะภูฟ้าไงเขาก็แย่งเราต้องขีด
ไว้ก่อนไหมเราตอบ
สี
ชายกับผู้หญิงสีส้มนะทุกหญิงตอบได้ 1 ผู้
หญิงก็จะขีดอ่ะลูกบาศก์ก็เลือกสีของครู
ฟ้าเอานะคะอ่ะคุณครูบารอมมั้ย 3 ต่อก่อน
เลย 30 วินาทีนะคะกีฬาอะไรที่ต้องใช้ความ
เร็ว ok นะแน่จริงๆ 2  3 เริ่มค่ะวิ่ง
กดแล้วอ่ะขอโทษค่ะคุณต้องกดใน iPad
ผู้หญิงจับเวลาใน iPad นักเรียนแต่ผู้
หญิง
ผู้หญิงมาเปิดอันนี้ให้นักเรียนดูไม่ต้อง
กดตรง start เนี่ยกดอยู่นั่นแหละว่าจะมา
มันไม่สตาร์ทโอเค 1  2  3 โรงอ่ะวิ่งว่าย
น้ำซอลอะไรล่ะอ๋อ
[เพลง]
ท้องดันออกก่อนที่อีกฝ่ายเราต้องตลกจังวะ
ลืมแล้วเปิด
ไฟฟ้าตอบเดียวเลยนะครับ 2
ไม่ตอบไม่ใช่ว่า 30 นาทีครูฟ้าตอบให้ได้
มากที่สุดมันส์ต้องฉันหลับกันกูมาลืมนะ
เอาใหม่ๆ
อะไรเนี่ยให้มันวิ่งจบไปก่อนนะคะนักเรียน
30 วินาทีคือฟ้าตอบก็คือผู้หญิงแล้วก็
ครูฟ้าแล้วก็ผู้หญิงใช่ไหมแต่ถ้าผู้หญิง
คิดนานก็สีฟ้าตอบได้เออ ok  ok อ่ะ
เดี๋ยวมันจะสอบว่ายน้ำเลยอ่ะก็พูดขึ้นมา
ก่อนโอเคนะคะพร้องนะกีฬาอะไรที่ต้องใช้
ความเร็ว 1  2  3 วิ่งว่ายน้ำ
ฟุตบอลๆ
ร้านจักรยานจักรยานปั่นจักรยานบาสเกตบอล
ลบแข่งแข่งรถ
เอ่ออ่าคิดไม่ออกเลยว่าอะไร
กีฬาอะไรที่ใช้ความเร็ว
ขว้าง
ความอันเร็วอะไม่ให้แก่โหลดเวลาถาม
อ่ะน้องขยับทุกครั้งนั้นนักเรียนบอกเวลา
แล้วน้องข้อที่ 1 เนี่ยครูฟ้าได้เท่าไหร่
กูก็บอกอะไรไม่ว่างอ่ะวิ่ง
มากินมอนฟุตบอล
อะไรนะ
รถก็ตอบอีกคนถามก็ได้ 3 เหมือนกันไงว่าย
น้ำมันจักรยานแข่งรถนะคะอ่าก็ที่ 1 เนี่ย
ครูบาสมีผู้หญิงสักเท่ากัน
ขอ 12 ค่ะ
อะไรคะผู้หญิงอันนี้เป็นอาชีพใช่ไหมอาชีพ
เนาะอาจจะเป็นช่างนะคะเป็นคุณหมอ
เนี่ยเป็นพยาบาลหรอแต่ข้อที่สองเนี่ยเรา
จะถามว่าอาชีพอะไรที่ต้องใช้ภาษาอังกฤษ
โอ๊ตใช้พลังงานอ่ะต้องพูดภาษาอังกฤษในการ
ทำงานอย่างคู่หญิงกับครูฟ้าใช่ไหมเป็นครู
สอนภาษาไทยแบบ a  genius เจอรัลด์
Approach แชร์นะคะไม่ต้องใช้ภาษาอังกฤษ
ไงแต่คำถามก็คืออาชีพอะไรที่ใช้ภาษา
อังกฤษนะคะ
ฝันกินอะไรนะคิดเอาไว้กินไว้ใช้
หนัง
x อุปทองขีดเอาไว้แล้วล่ะว่าตัวเองตอบ
อะไรบ้างนะคะ
โอเคครองนะคะครูฟ้า
คนขี่ที่ไหนได้บ้างไหมที่หน้าจอได้ก็ว่า
เหตุที่หน้าจอได้
โอเคนะคะ
1  2  3 เริ่มครู
หมอ
ล่าง
แอร์โฮสเตส
อา
ตื่นเต้น
สุดๆ
ใช้
เหมือนกัน
อ่าพนักงานโรงแรม
อ่า
เน็ตเวลา
อาเย้เอง
ฟ้าสแมน
ตอนที่ 2 นะครูฟ้า 3 ขลุ่ย 4 นะคะใครจะ
ได้กินมะนาวอ่ะข้อต่อไปนะคะรูปนี้เนี่ย
อันนี้ข้อที่ 3 ป่ะกูฟ้า
ข้อที่ 3 ข้อที่ 3 ปฏิ 3 นะคะรูปนี้เนี่ย
รูปอะไรคะครูป๊ารูปนี้หรอ
งานบ้านนะงานบ้านใช่ไหมอ่ะทำกับข้าวรีด
ผ้าซักผ้าถูบ้านดูดฝุ่นล้างจานนะคะทั้ง
หมดเนี่ยเป็นงานบ้าน
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยข้อที่ 3 นะครูฟ้าต้องคิดว่า
งานบ้านอะไรที่ที่เราทำทุกวัน
เฮ้ยการวันอังคารวันพุธเมื่อวันพฤหัสวัน
ศุกร์วันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์ทำทุกวัน
งานบ้านอะไรได้ค่ะพร้อมนะคะครูบาเดี๋ยวก็
ขยับนิดนึงนะคะนักเรียนอะลองขีดด้วยเนาะ
โอเค
1  2
3 เรื่องค่ะหลังจานถูบ้าน
รดน้ำต้นไม้
เก็บที่นอน
ดูดฝุ่น
รีดผ้าทุกวันไหม
ถ้านายก็ได้เก็บโต๊ะเช็ดโต๊ะเช็ด
เคาน์เตอร์แถวเจอร์เปล่าเช่าเข้าไปงาน
บ้างไหมกูเป็นไว้อาจจะทำอาหาร
โอเค
กูสาวทำหาสิ่งก็ได้ถึงข้าวเนาะได้หุงข้าว
ถ้าไม่งั้นเอาค.
ศ.ชุดนักเรียนผู้หญิงนักเรียน
ไปเลยฮักกันแนนเปิดนี้
เกมนี้เกมนี้เกมนี้ครูฟ้า 5 คะแนนคู่หญิง
4 คะแนนเกมต่อไปนะคะเกมต่อไป
กูมาเห็นอะไรคะครูฟ้าเห็น
ประเทศไทยค่ะครูหญิงประเทศไทยใช่ไหม
ประเทศไทยและมีภาคเหนือ
ภาคตะวันตกภาคกลาง
ภาคอีสาน
ภาคตะวันออกนะค่ะแล้วก็อุ้ยสีเทากันภาค
ใต้ใช่ไหม
อ้าวในแต่ละภาคเนี่ยก็จะมีจังหวัดใน
จังหวัดอะอย่างจังหวัดที่เชียงใหม่
เชียงใหม่อยู่ภาคอะไรเชียงใหม่อยู่ภาค
เหนือเชียงใหม่ภู่เกตุ
ภูเก็ตอยู่ภาคใต้
เนี่ยเป็นจังหวัดนะคะแต่ว่าว่าขลุ่ยใช้
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยภาคเหนือเนี่ยไม่เอาตะวันตก
ไม่เอาอีสานไม่เอาตะวันออกไม่เอาภาคใต้
ไม่เอาครูฟ้าจับครูหญิงเนี่ยต้องบอกว่า
ถ้ากลางภาคกลางเนี่ยนะคะมีจังหวัดอะไร
บ้างที่อยู่ในภาคกลาง
แยกหรอก็ไม่มั้งจะออกไปนายน่ะ
อ้ะ
เดี๋ยวเคลียร์ก่อนนะคะเป็นนนท์โอเค
30 วินาทีหนาจังหวัดที่อยู่ภาคกลางแล้ว
ก็ได้ผู้หญิงกับครูฟ้าจะรู้เข้าก็ผิดแสวง
อยู่ภาคกลางโอเคนะคะครูฟ้าพร้อมนะคะภาค
กลางฟ้า
ได้คุยก็อยากนี้
คุณคิดอะไรอยู่ค่ะ
2  3 เริ่มอยุธยา
สุพรรณบุรี
กรุงเทพฯอ่างทอง
นนทบุรี
ปราการปทุมธานีอ่า
ลพบุรี
นครสวรรค์ชัยนาท
สิงห์บุรี
I
บ่ไทยไหมอยู่ตรงข้ามไปยังอ่ะยังแพงเพชร
ในเท่าจดแล้ว
ไม่รู้ว่าเน็ต 4  5  6  7 เท่ากัน
หมอก็บอก
กรุงเทพฯใช่ๆความเค้าพูดถูกหมดเลยผู้หญิง
เนี่ย
สุโขทัยกับกําแพงเพชรอยู่ภาคกลางไหม
โต๋ถ้าอยู่ภาคกลางไม่หรอ
ไทคากาสก็แพงเสร็จตัวภาคกลางแล้วสุโขทัย
ภาคกลางเราข้อนี้นะคะได้เท่ากันซึ่งต้อง
ใครจะได้กินมะนาวเอ้อ
ก็เท่ากันทั้งหมดเนี่ยกิน
อ่ะข้อสุดท้ายก็คือสายเข้าสุดท้ายเนี่ย
ไม่มีรูปหาข้อที่ 5
ปฏิหาริย์นะคะอ่าข้อที่ 5 เนี่ยก็คือให้
ครูฟ้ากับครูหญิงเนี่ยคิดว่าอันนี้เป็น
เป็นโรคใช่ไหมคะอันนี้เป็นโรคเนาะนี่คือ
วงกลมนะคะนักเรียนแต่ว่าวงกลมไหมกูจะมี
โรคไม่มีแค่หน้าดาเมริกาจีนญี่ปุ่น
แอฟริกานะคะโลก
ไม่ใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็มีประเทศไทยในประเทศ
อเมริกาประเทศแคนาดาประเทศเม็กซิโก
แล้วแต่ละประเทศในก็จะพูดภาษาไม่เหมือน
กันประเทศไทยพูดภาษาอะไร
ภาษาไทยอ่ะประเทศอเมริกาพูดภาษาอะไรภาษา
อังกฤษ
ประเทศสเปนพูดภาษาอะไรภาษาสเปนแต่ว่าเรา
จะมาแข่งกันให้พูดชื่อประเทศที่พูดภาษา
อังกฤษ
โหเป็นภาษาที่แบบ TV นะเวลาดูทีวีเป็น
ภาษาอังกฤษอย่างนี้ว่าเราเรียกว่าเป็น
ภาษาที่พูดแบบเหมือนคนไทยอ่ะคนไทยทุกคน
ต้องพูดภาษาไทยใช่ไหม
ก็
ไม่ยากนะแต่ว่าเราจะพูดได้หมดหรือเปล่าใน
เวลา 30 วินาทีนะคะพี่ถ้า
พูดภาษาอังกฤษหรอมีอะไรบ้างล่ะประเทศที่
พูดภาษาอังกฤษนะผู้หญิงก็พอนึกออกอยู่นะ
ก็ได้อยู่โอเคนะคะพร้อมนะครับครูฟ้า 1  2
3 เริ่มค่ะอ่า
อังกฤษอเมริกาแคนาดานิวซีแลนด์
สิงคโปร์ออสเตรเลีย
แอฟริกา
ใต้อเมริกาใต้อา
ซ้อแลนด์
Switzerland
พูด
พูดเร็วเร็วๆ
อะไรอ่ะไม่ได้
เอาไปแล้วหรอที่เราไปแล้ววันนี้ไอร์แลนด์
อีก
[เพลง]
จะได้กินอ่ะข้อห้ามนี้จะได้
ก็วันนี้ครูฟ้าได้เท่าไหร่คะ
4 คะแนนค่ะ
ครูฟ้าได้ 4 ผู้หญิงได้ 5
เราก็ใส่ชนะนะคะ
ทำไมทำหน้าอย่างนั้นนะคะอุ้ยอุ้ยๆอุ้ย
อะไรก็หญิงไม่รู้
อะไร
โอเคครูหญิงเร็วที่สุดนะผู้หญิงเร็วกว่า
ครูฟ้าครูฟ้ามีมะนาวไหมคะมีให้ผู้หญิงฟ้า
นั้นมีมะนาวมานะคะฟ้าแพ้ใช่ไหมช้ากูมากิน
มันเท้าค่ะว่าต้องกินมะนาวหรอคะถ้าให้ถาม
กูมาต้องผู้ฟังนี่ไม่ได้หันมะนาวมาเลย
เหรอคะโอเคแล้วก็มาแล้วป่ะนะฮะ Now ใส่
ป่า
กูไม่ดีนะเดี๋ยวกูมาได้กินเข้าไปนั่งอ่าน
นักเรียนเลยหรอกินมัน
หือ
[เพลง]
แล้วพอแล้วพอแล้วก็แล้วออกมาได้
วันนี้เนอะผู้หญิงกับครูป๊านะคะจะเล่นเกม
แข่งกันว่าใครเร็วที่สุดเนาะตอบคำถาม
เกี่ยวกับกีฬาที่ใช้ความเร็วสมัยเหมือน
วิ่งนะคะอาชีพที่ต้องพูดภาษาอังกฤษหมาย
ถึงตา L เออสเตดประกอบและ
ล่ามนะเรอะข้อที่ 3 เราถามอะไรคะอ่ะหัว
ข้อที่ 3 เราถามว่าจังหวัดจังหวัดในภาค
กลางน้องแล้วก็งานบ้านที่ต้องทำทุกวันไหม
ล้างจานทำอาหารแล้วก็ดี 5 ก็คือประเทศที่
พูดภาษาอังกฤษอเมริกานิวซีแลนด์แคนาดานะ
คะว่าวีดีโอนี้ให้ครูฟ้าเค้าไปดื่มน้ำ
ก่อนนะคะเปรี้ยวนักเรียนผู้หญิงเร็วที่
สุด yes สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ